So today we're going to
Turn our attention.
to vectors
We will briefly revisit.
today, of course the sixth of July
revisit
the fundamentals of abstract algebra
and get into context of vectors vectors and Vector spaces
because we want to talk about vector addition.
And we want to visualize vector vector
operations vectors and
The Rock Creations using python.
And I also want to talk about the applications of
vector operations.
I hopefully we'll be able to.
move
Fast enough to get into something called cosine similarity. So
here's what we're going to do today. We're going to talk about vector.
operations
and it will also I'll take you
for a moment to abstract algebra.
document that we had before
we are going to visualize vectors.
with math plot lip both in 2D
and 3D
then
to look at a practical application of course vectors have
immediately applications in physics
But I want us to look at applications in.
You know machine learning in particular.
things like topic modeling and
finding words that are similar.
To words in a dictionary so I give an example where I
said, you know, when you Google something a word and that
is misspelled.
Google gives you the closest.
The water is closest to what you have typed.
So in order for us to understand one the
following application of vector operations,
I'm referring to cosine similarity.
We need to First.
talk about
a coordinate system that we have not yet talked about but it is
very important.
especially if you ever want to learn
and apply differentially equations
So I've mentioned the Cartesian coordinate system.
Which has a developed version of the euclidean?
coordinate system
But we haven't talked about something called the
polar coordinate system. So Cartesian.
and polar
coordinate systems
the coordinate system uses
points
to
You know place a vector.
In a polar coordinate system, however, we use angles.
to place a vector to draw a vector onto the graph
and
we want to see how we can go back and forth.
So another for us to be able to plot the cosine similarity
of two vectors. We will need to go from a Cartesian.
To our polar coordinate system or at least what will
happen is we will go from you will get
an angle. Basically you will get an angle of multiple vectors.
And then in order to convert that into the Cartesian coordinate
system.
we have to
probably have to convert it. I'll show you how to do the conversion.
So cosine similarity and
application
in
well, I mean
put NLP.
But cosine similarity has broad applications. It's
not limited to NLP.
Okay, so let's begin.
and speaking of
angles
we might I might even talk about trigonometry. So
do a quick trigonometry.
review
But this is hopefully a more useful review because I am
going to be fixated on the side.
the sign let's say
function
Okay.
So let me open a new document here.
We'll call this vectors.
dot MD
and I'm going to copy.
Snippets of code from my notes
and then we'll do the same python.
All right. So where did I put this thing?
in
linear algebra
So, of course, we've already established that vectors are
sets.
of elements
But of course these are special sets.
Because certain axioms apply these sets
so to make a distinction.
Between a generic set and special set.
We use the word space.
or
Vector actually let me correct myself a vector
is a special set.
And the vectors in turn are subsets of another set
called the space. So that's what we get Vector space.
Okay.
so
I'm sure you remember this tutorial because this is the first tutorial we had.
in module 1
so we said that sets can be denoted in different
ways.
using
Curly braces aren't common.
So it's either going to be used or either we will use.
a parentheses or
square brackets
so
an equivalent way
or expressing
a vector
is also use square brackets.
And we are going to use these interchangeably
so it depends on.
How we want to visualize?
Vectors if if we're talking about a point in
a 2d or 3D coordinate space you will use
this we will use the parentheses.
but if we're talking about
transposing a vector or
extracting effective for Matrix. We will use a square brackets.
Okay.
then
I told you that.
We have a formal definition for a vector.
Let me copy that bit of code.
Okay, maybe I don't have it. So let me just write down the vector space
because this is related to
the vector operations that we're going to look at.
so
LP tutorial on empty
Master tutorial
Yeah.
And then we have so this is the vector space.
the vector space
so a vector space
Is a set of vectors.
To which the following actions apply a vector
addition and Vector multiplication.
And these axioms apply under closure?
Again, that means if you take two vectors.
They will be.
You will get a third element that will be subset of the vector space.
So two vectors added add them together notice to these two are both
add two vectors together. You'll get a third Vector multiply two
vectors. You will get a you will again get a vector.
And you will get a vector of the same Dimension. So we
also talked about the r and space.
right
So if you want to indicate that you're talking about.
a vector with two points or 3.4 points
you would use r
to the power
Okay, so R to the power 3 is the set of
all vectors that have three components.
again, the words components elements
Members is all interchangeable.
So that's a point in a three-dimensional space. These are
points.
Actually, this is a this is one point with five
elements.
And this is one point with three elements. I have to be careful with my
words.
Okay.
And of course we talked about fields which we set
our special types of rings.
So if I pull up the linear algebra tutorial.
I meant to say abstract algebra tutorial.
Which is number seven?
number seven
Okay, so field is a type of ring.
So it has all eight axioms of a ring plus a
ninth was called the inverse. So we will be able to do this
to vectors as well again, if I
scroll up here, these are the eight.
axioms that apply
To a field where is the field again? Yeah, so these are the eight
actions that apply to a field.
question from Ron it applies ABC and are real
the the members of
the vector are real correct multiplication of
vector space is usually a and r
I think you're referring to this document.
multi-multiplicate multiplication
in a vector space is usually in R V and
V.
So if a is a really okay here do you
mean by a is a vector or a is a real number?
Because you just have the letter a in there. I don't know
if it's so for better multiplication.
Mm-hmm usually means a scalar times a vector.
Is also in the vector space.
Okay, correct.
If I look at my text, let me see if they have this additional
comet.
But okay there is vector addition and scalar multiplication.
Better multiplication as you've written it.
it's only applicable to
R3
okay, so let me correct myself then.
from my math background
Yeah, you might be correct because yours is Vector vision and secular multiplication
the product effective language.
you
This one doesn't use.
Bold letters or arrows over the on top of the letter so
I have to read the text to figure out.
The correct code. Okay, then I'll just
have to correct. Correct myself.
I always try this then so let me for the time being get rid
of.
Now I just correct it. I'll correct in a moment.
But let me I'll fix this.
I'll fix this right in a second.
But let me just show you how to draw vectors using mathplotlib.
Okay.
I'm gonna create a new file here.
And I will call this vectors.
dot i p y and B
and I'm gonna go ahead and import.
matplotlib dot Pi plot
Just PLT and import.
number numpy as NP
Okay.
And this is my reference code.
vectors
Yes, there are scalar multiplication. There's no Vector multiplication.
This is incorrect.
scalar multiplication
and this has to be
I will use.
e to stand for component
Yes, I hope we can see that this the ball so that that's a vector.
That's a constant.
Multiply the scalar by the vector you will get and you
will get another Vector you will get a vector that obvious. That
would be a subset at the vector space.
Okay.
and
V is a vector
Okay. So now I see what you were saying
Richard. I will say here that this is a subset of
the real.
number system
and this is a
constant component
There we go.
Okay.
I just wanted to fix that code because it was bothering me now. Let
me go ahead and return to the notebook.
And we will also see how this this this.
The you know appears when
we plot the numbers.
When we plot the vectors.
now I'm going to I've written some created some
functions that allow us to
create
vectors
let me show you one example of
creating a drawing a line on math powder because
with mathpotlib the way you draw a line on a
plot.
Is by creating a sequence of
points?
XY points
and then get that gives the
the appearance of there being aligned. So let me show you some simple
example.
First I will create a figure.
and assign
a variable ax to the axis of the figure
and by doing this we can set the limits of
the axes.
Set the labels of the axes. So I'll show
you what I mean.
And I'm going so here I'll do just that I'm going
to have this is going to be a two-dimensional example. So this is
Get rid of that vectors in 2D.
The x-axis will go from negative 15 to
15.
The y-axis will go from 0 to 10.
So we'll have the two quadrants of the Cartesian system.
Then I'm going to create.
a sequence of points
So again, how do we plot a simple Point
Let's see. We have P1.
and this will be
let's say five and five.
of obviously the order is X and Y always the case
XY and then if there was a third of
Third axis. It will be Z.
And then the plot this point we would go.
It would go.
a x Dot Plot
P1 0 P 1
one
so P0 will be the point on the x-axis P1
would be the point of the y axis.
very straightforward
import the libraries
and
I need to set the marker and the color.
now actually, no, I don't need to do that, but why isn't
appearing so I actually
Set the color here. Try making it black.
and the size
No, actually this the first two arguments would be sufficient. It's
not appearing because
It should be here.
one of my missing
that's correct.
Come on, this is just a simple Point. Why am I not able to get it to
appear?
Okay, let's go. Are you?
You're only plotting one one element of the point. Yeah, I
just want it's just supposed to be one. That's if
I pull up the P1 is P1 is
one point or two points.
It's one point. So that's it's a position on the x-axis. So
five. Sorry only plotting the y coordinate.
No, this is the so it's supposed to
be five steps on the x-axis and
then five steps up the y axis so it
should be here.
Let me see what I'm doing wrong here.
Let me pull up the code I used for linear programming.
and P
here composition
export P color black marker size.
Okay, I shouldn't do I mean I don't need to put the marker size so
Maybe I maybe yeah, maybe for one point. I do need a markers.
So let's go back here. Put the markers.
It should have a default value, right?
anyway
Let me make the markers. Well, thank you Richard. So yeah,
so that's that's what I want to show you. That's the marker.
and so
in order for us to draw a line from the origin.
to this point
we need to create a sequence of these points.
So something.
to this effect
this would be
let's say
this is the first point.
A second point this is the third point.
And let's just make this two to two five five.
and seven seven
and I will write this code.
copy this code
This will be P2.
This will be P3.
So we can get a line to go this way.
Now. There are two types of vector three types of vectors. There
are.
positioned vectors
That can appear anywhere.
There are displacement vectors.
at this
A position Vector is one where let me
actually show you the pictures. Just easier to explain what
pictures so position.
versus displacement
vector
and there's something called. I have velocity Vector. We're
going to look at this, but the one that we're doing is called a displacement vector.
so a position vector
Is something like this?
It's for example the line segment, OA.
But it is not.
Associated with some origin or as displacement Vector
is associated with position and the from the origin.
Okay.
and I'll tell you why I'm bringing that
up because
when we do vector addition I want to
We will displace a vector to show
you so we can understand what's going on with the with
the addition.
Anyway, what I'm going to do now is I'm going to use a
code from numpy. They'll allow me to
generate.
Like a hundred such points.
And that will give the appearance of a line.
Okay, so instead of doing this manually, I'm
going to get rid of these.
and I'm going to use
a sequence of points to you know
to give the impression of a line.
And here's the code. So the Republic called.
lens space linear space from numpy
so we go and P Dublin space.
And this takes three arguments.
the
so you're going to create a list of values, right?
the starting number
the ending number. Let's say 5.
and then the number of
values
that you will generate from 0 to 5. So if I say 100
and you will get something, you know like this.
Small links leading all the way to 5 that's 100 points.
That's for the now let's say this is for the x-axis. So I'm going to
go x equals NP that linear space.
0 to 5 and then the same thing for the y-axis.
And I can go back to ax Dot
Plot.
The plot argument can the plot method can either take a single
a scalar value or in this case a list
of values?
I'm going to go X and Y.
And I don't need to do anything else. I believe there
we go. Yeah, for some reason when you when you
are plotting with lists of
with a list of code, excuse me.
What the values that are lists you don't need to supply the additional arguments,
but there we go.
The way the reason we're able to see this line is because
we have
100 points on this quarter 100x and
y's
Now what I want to do is I want to show multiple vectors, but
I don't want to use this kind of code. So I've created.
or have abstract the way the code so
there is this function.
That I have created it's called.
back
So I'm going to get rid of these.
And it takes as argument.
the X and Y points
as a tuple so points will be a tuple of XY.
Then the optionally the displacement along
the X and Y axis.
And all it's going to do is it's going to well start
at the on the x-axis. It will start at the
origin by default at zero.
It will start at the origin.
and
the
stopping position on the x-axis
and it will generate a hundred sequence of numbers just like
we saw.
And then it will return the Tuple.
of
this so this will be a list. This will be a list and there
will be in a tuple, but we'll convert this to not
by array. Why because what we want to perform the vector addition
and scalar multiplication.
And numpy object would allow us to do
that do that.
Then I have another function called Draw.
So this will create a linear space for a vector.
And this will draw the vector on the subplot.
So this will take as argument a vector.
which will be
a tuple where the elements are lists
so
Basically, we will be this V.
Will be something that looks like this.
Okay a list of values from 0.
0.01 Baba all the
way to for example 5
and the same thing for the y-axis.
So when we do math, we really just need.
One point on the x-axis one point on the y-axis.
That will give us for example somewhere there. But since we
want to draw the line, we also have to generate the points leading
up to that point.
So that's what this function does.
That's what this function does that we pass it to the draw function.
And of course we can we once we have
Generated the vector. We can also displace it
after having generated it.
So if I remove these displacement
values you can see it's just
this is going to be the list of X points on
the along the x-axis. This will be the points along the y-axis.
And these are just additions to displaced the vector.
then I have this third function GP short for
get points.
I'll show you what this does in a second.
Okay, let me remove it for now. Let's just keep things simple.
Now I'm going to create two vectors.
V sub 1
Which will be a vector.
at the point
zero
five
So I don't need to what once I have created this
functions. I have abstracted the way the numpy stuff and
I can just you know, use Simple notation. So
V1 will be a vector from 0 to
5 V 2 will be a vector.
Let's make this one.
well
zero to negative 5
actually negative
Five, so this is five steps negative
five steps to the left.
and it will appear so we'll get a v
and then I'm going to draw these factors. I'm going to go draw.
The argument has to be the first
vector.
or V sub 1
and then V oops
T sub 2
and the draw function needs to know.
which method to call so I'm going to use
They plot method of the ax object
the axis object.
And this is supposed to be 5.
So there's five. There we go.
Okay.
so I'm gonna I'm not the reason I set the x-axis to
go from negative 15 to positive 15 because I don't
want to
move away from this point
It's just easier that way.
Okay. So, let's see what vectorization does.
I'm going to create a third vector.
And the third Vector will be the sum of the first
two vectors.
so in order to do this
I need to grab.
the coordinates of the first vector
so this function
GP get points will well give me the points of
the first Vector which is 5 and 5.
and
the point of the second Vector so V sub 2
and the way this function works is a pretty straightforward.
And bring it back here.
or we will take the
the list
from the vectors remember a vector in this notebook.
Is a tuple of arrays?
So we'll take the array and the x-axis and it
will just grab the last element.
So the ending the ending number and the same
thing for the y-axis and then we'll return and appearing.
Okay.
And then so I'm going to add these points together.
And then turn it to a vector.
I'm gonna draw this third.
Now back here.
And you might be able to see it.
But you can see now that the size of
this Vector is double.
these two vectors
So I'm going to draw this in a different way.
I'm going to
not draw the third Vector for a second.
And what I'm going to do is I'm going to align these vectors.
I'm gonna stack them up on top of each other actually. So the first
Vector will go from 0 to 0 to
Well zero to five so be a vertical
line.
And I'm going to take the second vector and
draw it on top of the first vector.
so this will be
0 on the axis x axis
okay, and
I'm gonna have to displace it here. So we get
this.
But I'm going to displace the second Vector. So
let's also use the colors here.
for colors I can use the
To which functions that I like color?
See, so second Vector. I will make it red.
And the first factor I will make it blue.
Okay.
why is it complaining about C because
yeah, these belong to the
draw function, sorry
And this will become blue.
Okay. Now I'm going to the I'm gonna displace the
Red line by Five Points. I'm
going to go.
Why displacement?
five
and then when I draw the Third
Vector I'm going to displace it five points
across the along the x-axis so
we can see these two we can see these vectors side by
side. So X displacement equals five.
There we go. So this is what the vectorization does.
you will get
the well
This is what it means you get the it becomes twice the length.
So I use this example because the examples, you know you I've
seen in books will not clear enough if I
type here vector addition.
You see examples like this.
Okay. Well, maybe this is clear enough.
or even this one
but by here, you know displacing it. I think it made it
very very clear.
Okay.
So I will now extend this code to create
a three-dimensional plot.
Okay, I'm going to collapse this create a new
section.
And this will be called.
vectors in 3D
So I've introducing to this code because we're going to later use this
for more advanced examples.
Okay.
Let me just copy the code.
So these
Are the same functions we saw before but for three
dimensions?
same as before, but now we have a z Axis or a
You know a linear space for the points along the
Z axis.
And of course, we're now adding a third.
list in this Tuple
to the points on
The three axes so same function just adapted for three
dimensions.
and if I want to create
one vector in this three-dimensional
as coordinate system
So for example 10 on the X and
Y and Z axis would get something that looks
like.
Like this, let me copy the figure information.
So this is the x-axis.
You can see if we look at it from the x-axis.
If I follow this Gray Line I go
all the way here.
It is 10 points away from the 10.
from the x-axis
case maybe here
then on the y-axis same thing.
on the y-axis
And of course the Z axis.
So you kind of have to imagine this is in a three-dimensional space.
right
And of course we can probably second one.
Let's change
this to.
20 on the Z axis, for
example
So going forward we're going to use this code to draw.
a vectors needed two or three dimensions
Okay. So the orange one obvious second Vector is higher.
And now this one goes up to 15. So let's make these point
on the Z axis 15.
Okay, so going forward we're going to use this source code.
Now, let me show you.
practical example
But now with vector addition because I think outside of
I can outside of physics. I can't come up with any.
practical example, so I'm just going to turn our
attention to
the polar coordinate system
We will talk about the polar coordinate system.
the magnitude of a vector
and then once we have the the magnitude we will
also look at
scalar multiplication
And then once we've covered these three, yeah, so
the polar coordinate system magnitude of
a vector scale of multiplication and then
we can Implement cosine Simon. It would be cool to plot the
rotate space. Yeah what there
was a greater library, but not math
problem that math problem is flat if you want to interactive one. There's something
called.
I think Seaborn does it but there's also one called
plot the I really like I really like this Library.
So if I could apply for python
Let me just Google pull partly 3D.
plot
It's a very simple to use Library when it comes in JavaScript. So
You know, you can create. Yeah, this is the one.
This is very cool. It can take snapshots of it.
You take that's a snapshot.
You can zoom in pan.
And maybe I'll give you the source code for using this Library. It's
pretty straightforward by them. Nothing spectacles. It's very
analogous to
matplotlip
So the same convention, you know.
You well this well, you need a daily frame. So
this could be the list of values and then so DF stands
for data frame and the data frame is simply a table.
X and Y points. So the left column would be the X
points y kind of would be the Y points.
Yeah, and you can also have you know, like a
heat density
It's a bit finicky to play around but this is this is one option.
I was just when you interacting with this not to keep your
mouse and on the on the plot move your
mouse outside of it if you don't want it to move.
But that's what that's what an optional I have. I have
several notebooks using this code. So I'll share that with you.
Okay.
Okay, let's return to our code.
And then we let's also see if we can do an example just on vector.
operations
so
let me give you.
Some background, of course hide similarity.
Before we cover the people acquisites.
cosine similarly for wood vectors if you remember
if you were there for the ml papers episode 1
I talked about representing words.
as
vectors
for each component in the vector was
a distribution. No, excuse me, a probability
under a topic.
For example something like this.
we had
two words word number one
and word number two
Where word number one I think was something like
cattle dog.
Okay, so it was up like 0.6.
zero point
five
.1. And let's just make this and by
the way, it has to add up to one so
This has to be less than 1 let's make this two.
That's eight nine and let's speak to 0.1.
And then for the second word, this could be 0.5.
zero point
two as well.
0.05 0.05
And the these numbers so these are probabilities,
which means they are a number between 0 and
1.
but the order
of these values matters
so if we talking about and by the way, we're going to look in an
application for
natural language processing module for so we're already setting
up the foundation here the first element.
Is every element here this every probability here is
a social topic. So for example, we can have team of topic
one topic two.
topic 3
topic 4
where topic the topics are
about the following
So let's say this is a DOT. This is Kevin. This
is dog.
This could have to do with mammals.
mmm
this can have to do with
I think these numbers are too close to each other.
They're not strong enough.
Let me make this four and make this.
And let's pop up these numbers.
three
So the first one has to with let's say pets.
Then the second one has to with mammals.
And then basically it becomes
less relevant. What could be something that is?
It's very slightly relevant to cats and dogs.
anesthesia
And the fort will be something really irrelevant.
building
or not as relevant, you know.
Basically to produce what vectors like
this you would go through series of articles.
or pages in a book
and
Books come in different topics. We have novels. We
have fiction. We have textbooks on.
linear algebra
And the way we will know what
these words mean semantically is how
frequently they appear.
in books of different subject matters
Now we'll talk about producing vectors like this by the way. Okay, when
we get to module 4, we'll talk about producing board
vectors. But anyway.
Here as if the number is higher for the first.
Index that that means these two words
are associated with pets. Okay. So let's say this is
a word for dog.
And this is a word for cat.
Okay, so since they both are talking they're both pets
so they would.
Have higher probabilities.
They also a mammals so they have.
Higher probability at least compared to
anesthesia and buildings.
But that's the idea. Let's say there was a third word.
Something unrelated. This would be zero point.
zero one
just flat zero.
or anesthesia
It will be zero point.
seven no zero point three
And this will be zero point.
I can make it six nine.
So 69 plus 0.1 would be 70 plus 3. Can
you imagine what this would
what what this word could possibly be?
It is highly it has a high distribution for anesthesia. And
it's very likely of building. What do you think this?
would could be
strong association with anesthesia and buildings
Hospital exactly
Hospital
No.
let's say we want to have a system where we
group or put words under categories
and we want to do this automatically. We don't want to do this manually.
So for example, let's say you want to create
a social media application and you want to
maybe remove words or remove
posts that have to do with
you know inappropriate topics.
I guess for something inappropriate you could make a list of words.
So you won't need to use cosine similarity. But let's
let's think about a more useful example where we
want to.
You know, like let's think about words that can mean
very different things in different contexts.
So the name of a company like apple,
right? Apple could be the fruit. It can also be
a company.
How we know what it means? It depends on the text surrounding it.
Or topics or books if you want to or a
web pages you want to associate web pages by
different topics. So this webpage is about Finance. This
web page is about sports. This web page is about
You know.
football whatever
How would we?
How would you go about classifying it when everything we have?
is a vector of numbers like so
okay.
Let me show you what an example.
Let's say we have we have these three words and they represented
as vectors of distributions.
Cosine similarity is about this.
I'll show you how we calculus in a moment.
But it is the angle.
created by these two vectors
the smaller the angle the closer they are to
each other.
They have a closer meaning they're associated with each other enough. Obviously the farther they're
apart.
The the less similar they
are this is a very good example. This is a very nice picture so you
can see the cosine similarity of
drone
or they call the the angle of drone and helicopter
and Rocket are
Closer to each other relative to you know
Goose eagle and B.
So if you would take the cosine similarity of drone and
Eagle you would have
what we call an up.
Is that an obtuse is that an obtuse angle? But it's a
it's not even it's even less than 45 degrees.
Anyway, you'll get a bigger cosine symbolarity and
acute angle.
And a cute angle. Thank you. And I actually yeah a cute
would be narrow, right?
Anyway, what I'm trying to say is the the larger the
angle the less similar they are so for example B and Rocket,
you know.
They're very dissimilar.
So what I want to show you is how to produce such a thing.
In order for us to plot vectors like this.
After having calculated their cosine similarity. We need
to talk about the polar coordinate system.
So let's first talk about.
The first prerequisite okay.
this is going to be about
cosine
similarities or similarity
And the polar coordinate system.
and this this will be a foundation for
other topics that will be covering this course, but later on even for differential equations
why differential equations but because
The prerequisite for differential equations in particular partial differential
equations is complex analysis.
And you know in complex analysis we have these imaginary numbers.
And so we use the polar coordinate system extensively.
Okay.
anyway
The first thing we need to what I'm going to show you is the formula for
cosine similarity. So I'm going to return to
vectors
That's create a new section here. Call cosine.
similarity
And the formula is this.
If I can remember correctly.
it is cosine of
Theta
would be
the product of two
vectors
A and B
Okay.
dot actually not
sum out here. See what I'm doing wrong teeth rack.
and the magnitude of the
vector
Vector a c dot. Okay, there's the problem of activity.
over the magnitude
What was the code what I keep forgetting cosine similarity
to formulas boy?
Yeah, the magnitude of the first Vector times. The magnet is
not the second Vector. So I'm going to go.
Vector a
times
Vector B
Okay.
You use double bar?
As far as I know.
using two bars or
Single bar doesn't make a difference. Actually, it
is preferable to use double bar
because single bar could be mistaken for the absolute value.
It's best to use double bars.
And I don't want to create a space. That's that big. I just want a small space.
So I'm just going to use the column.
Yeah, that's much better.
That's how we calculate the cosine similarity.
Let me show you how this is done with python.
And of course, this will give you a number.
We'll give you an angle.
So, let's see how this is done.
And this is incorrect. This is you will get the angle Theta that
will be the
result of this evaluation whereas
this is not cosine. This is cosine similarities.
So I'm gonna
make it cosine somewhere.
And this would be it will take two arguments.
vectors A
and P
that's much better.
So yeah, if you calculate the cosine similarity of these two
vectors.
both sides similarity
you would get the angle Theta and that's how you'll know how far
these words are apart from each other.
So let me show you how to do first calculate this with python and
then how to plot it.
So I'll return to vectors IP ymb.
And then we bring you the code.
cosine similarity
first we have the magnitude.
Now, let me talk about the magnitude by the way.
The magnitude of a vector is
calculated as follows. I think I had it from before but let me
write it down anyway.
mangani, tude
So that's this term here in the denominator.
to calculate the magnitude
is to stick this is the square all
the
components of the vector
add them all up and then take the square root of the sum.
So we get something that looks like this.
We will first add up all the components of the vector.
So let's say the vector has components ABC and
we'll have
a squared
Again, we have an arrow over the AOK. So these two are distinct
are over Amy's Vector. This is component of that
Vector a squared plus b squared plus c squared.
If for example, this is over R3.
and then we take the square root of
this sum.
So down here we're doing we're taking the magnitude 4.
both vectors
So, how do we calculation python?
Here, let me close this.
what I'm doing here is
enumerating
over all the components in the vector v. So V is
a vector.
And we denote X.
Let me put x sub. I just to make it especially clear x
sub I is a component.
Xabi is a component in v in the vector v.
Now what we're doing is I have I'm going to import the math Library by
the way. We need to import the math Library.
I will take every extra by
of v and it raise it to the power too. So this is the power method.
X is the base 2 is the power just like we saw
earlier.
This will give us a list.
X sub 1 squared x sub 2 squared x sub 3
squared and then we will use the sum function that's built into python to
add up all the elements in this set.
Once we have the sum.
I think the square root.
And that's of course how you calculate the magnitude?
To calculate cosine similarity of two vectors we do
this.
Okay, this function will take two arguments two vectors.
First we have the numerator.
So we multiply these two vectors together.
and then the denominator
which is the product of
their magnitude
and then the return value of course is the fraction.
Okay.
So now let me show you.
Let me show you how to calculate this for those three wood
vectors.
Okay.
Just one
of the copy.
and
For the numerative actually want to take the dot product. Let
me make sure numpy doesn't have a method for the dot product.
Okay, there is another three dot product.
You're about to say something.
wrong
I was just gonna say yeah, there is a DOT product on NP
array.
Yes.
Okay, when I use this I got the correct results. So is I
want to make sure I want to see if Matt Mall.
is a
is the general case of the dot method?
Okay.
Let me what I'll do is I'll first run the cosine similarity on those two
word vectors.
And then I'll change this to dots if I get a different result. Okay.
So let's go first let's do that. I'm gonna
go cosine similarity of word Vector
one.
and would Vector 2
if I run this
it has a midst undefined maybe run this again.
not that
We get well, it's almost 1.
If I do the same for let me see first of all, if I put dot do
I get a different value?
No, okay, so Matt Mall as a
general you the the dot method it's
a method on NP. So you have to
write it as V1 dot Paran V2
close friend.
Is it not this?
But that's not I guess that works too.
But the one I use it's that is also a method on NP
array so you can do V1 dot
V2. Okay, so
like so be two one dot or would
one for example what?
Is that what you mean?
Yeah, we would see yeah, then put the r value in the
parenthesis. Yeah.
But yeah, but I think is I haven't turn this into MP race so that would
mean I'd have to make this in pra.
And then this would be MP array.
How many arguments what are the parameters of dot if
I expand this?
But this should work.
Yeah, okay.
Yeah, okay fine that Auto's awesome
option.
Okay. So yes, we take the dot put the new
bridge the dot product of those two vectors.
And I'll show you the picture. I'll go to Google Images to show
you an example of that product how it's done the order.
And the denominator is the
product of the magnitude.
So anyway, that's the cosine similarity of the first two words.
Let's look at the cosine similarity of Ward 1 and Ward 3.
I can see it's it's
it's smaller number.
So they are.
Not relevant. What about word to one word three?
Yeah, still not as high as these two.
Now these are angles.
How do you plot these angles on?
a plot like
like that one. So, how can we visualize this?
So to do this we need to
Convert from Polar to coordinate system. What
is a polar quad system? Let's come over here.
I'm going to go.
folder
Cartesian coordinates
Let's look at this picture.
I wish this was a high resolution, but this should do.
when you if you remember how we started our session today, we we
said that
we put a point on the Cartesian space.
And in math, we just draw a line, but in
Python, we have to create a sequence of points leading up to that
point.
so for example five steps of along the
x-axis and then five steps along the y-axis and
that's where we put the point and that we do a line leading to
that point.
But if you notice here when we do draw this Vector we have now formed an
angle.
We have formed an angle from the
x-axis to the
line
There's a word for this I think there's initial side
and the terminal side. So there's the initial side.
Relative to the x-axis is the initial side. That's the terminal
side relative to the Y axis that would be the initial side and
this would be
The terminal side and any
rate. So on the Cartesian coordinate system,
we have the points X and Y, excuse me.
We have the values X and Y and that produces the point.
in the polar coordinate system we have
R which is the radius
and the coordinate the polar quarter system is a circle. We'll see
this in a second and the angle Theta
So if you know these values if you know the the length
of the vector.
and it's
Angle from the initial side, then you will know its
position on the polar coordinate system, but there's a way we can convert we
can go from one system to another system.
Let me show you the polar coordinate system on its own polar coordinate
system.
Yeah, this is how it's done.
Okay.
These are the coordinates.
on the
political system obviously
the point one point would be the length of the vector that
will always be the case and then
the
there is radian. And what's the other one? Yeah in radians how
how far it is from the
initial side.
Okay.
And this is the radiant system you get
the idea. Hope.
okay, so if you want to for example go from
Polar to
Cartesian you calculate it this way.
Let me write it down here. I have a comment. I have a
note here.
So if you want to go from
Artesian
To polar or polar to court to Polo to
Cartesian from Polar.
coordinate
to Cartesian
we do this.
For the for the point on the x-axis.
We go X will be equal to
R.
Which is the radius?
times
sine of sine of yeah sign of
the angle Theta
And if you want the Y.
You multiply by.
the cosine
Theta
This is how you convert.
We know have the angle Theta for our cosine similarity
now. We just need to multiply it. But well
we need to
Calculate the sign of that.
Angle which will give us the ratio.
for sign it will be the ratio will be
opposite over opposite over hypotenuse, right
and cosine would be
Opposite, hold on a minute. What was the what was the mnemonic sign
is? So katoa, right? Yeah, I just over
hypotenuse.
I don't like the mnemonic what is house by the way, I I was hoping
that maybe if this time I'll tell you where this word sign
comes from.
If we know the origin of the word sign.
It will be nothing it will
okay immediately tell you where the other words come from.
But anyway, let's let's do this first let's get this out of the way. So if
I want the X and Y from my cosines and similarity, I'm
going to come back to my notebook.
Let me bring this up here.
I will call this.
Cos or see some one
because I'm similarity for the first comparison.
cosine
let's make it one and two right the cosine similarity of vectors
1 and 2 the cosine similarity of
vectors.
Two and three or let's make this one and three.
to convert to
Cartesian
what's
now
we cannot plot these wood vectors because
these are we gonna We
have to project projectors in the two-dimensionals.
Space these are four dimensional.
So what we're going to do is we're going to create two
vectors.
That go from all from 0 to 5. Basically, let
me show you what I mean. Okay, so
I'm going to create those three vectors again.
Let this be.
w
Sub V1, or the vector 4 would
1.
And this will be a vector with points.
0 to 5
and I'm going to draw this.
So we'll first draw.
the vector for word one
And then once now they have calculate this
of course as similarity, we know how far the other
two words are. This will be V. We what
one if I run this.
I need to type in your PX.
Okay.
equals
X
I need to borrow the code from about.
All the way up here.
copy these
the x-axis will go from 0 to 15. And also the y-axis will
go from 0 to 15.
On this one more time.
And what was my mistake here?
Let me come up here see right there before.
and 2D I
let's have actor.
just borrow this
what's the other mistake?
What's the issue?
It's literally the same code.
0 to 5 0 and 5
Let me just copy these functions again. Maybe I
Did something to overwrite what these were?
one more time
here
Okay.
These are the functions from before.
Again, the X will go from 0 to 15. This
will go shoot 15.
Okay, there are everything else is the same
run this one more time.
Now what?
Is it me or?
Something's different here.
the draw functions the same as before
That's the same as before. Why is it not up here?
Come on now.
see
Here should we right there?
This cannot be this has nothing to do with it.
Does have something to do with it?
something is wrong because
yes, yes. Yes. See I keep
making the mistake
This is not the origin. This is
Five five okay five steps from the x-axis five
steps for the y-axis.
Let me go back to what I had before.
I need to be more careful.
Okay, so that's the let me let me let me make
the vector a bit longer. So we'll go from 10 to 10.
Now after we have calculated the cosine similarity.
We need to grab the X and Y for the second.
vector
so
the formula was as follows if I want to draw the second
vector.
I'm going to go V.
W2
Okay.
the position of this Vector is relative to
Vector 1
so for its X
Or it's X I'm going to call the vector function to draw a
vector.
And this will have to be a tool.
So for we have X and Y, correct.
What is the X going to be X is going to be the radius? So
right now what what do you think is the radius of this vector?
I mean if this was our if this were on the polar coordinate step,
which it isn't right now, what would be its radius?
square root of 200
exactly 10
it will be 10. So that's the r
what was it then times?
the cosine of
Data, so here this is the our data.
So it's going to be mad.
What the signal of course? I think it was signed math that
sign of C.
Because I'm similarity of one or two.
Same thing for why it's gonna copy this bit.
But this would be cosine.
Okay. Now I'm going to draw the second vector.
We'll make this red.
Okay.
Oh, well, is it good or bad or it is closed or
not not close. There's only one way to not just to create a third vector.
So I'm going to create a third vector.
This will be the cause now the angle for these functions would
be the cosine similarity of 1 and 3.
So we first compare one and two now we compare one and three.
And let me make the first Vector black.
That's the def. That's our.
point of reference
and then we will make the green one.
Let me let me draw this again.
Just so you can see the black vector.
That's the original one.
and then
let's add the third vector.
third Factor
Now one more time because I forgot to change reassign
this value. So again, this is the first vector.
This was a dog right supposedly dog. This
was cat.
And now let's do the building.
And let's make the color.
green
Yeah.
So you can see.
dog and cat
all closer to each other have a
smaller angle
This cosine similar. I really like because
the broad applications and natural language processing
let me so let me see if I can show you an example.
a very simplified version of
autocomplete
But it's this idea clear that you understood what
we've done here like the purpose that up practical use
case of vectors.
And here the cosine similarity of
two word vectors.
Any questions before I?
Go any further.
No questions at all.
Okay. Why do you think about a question let me
Show you how we do this information retriever.
Now, how do we do it?
There's something called the individed index.
But that's not relevant. So let's
say we have the following words, right? We have apple.
We have application.
we have
what that doesn't even start with.
a Brazil
and let's do one more word.
We'll make this.
catapult
How these how are these words represented? Let
me let me let me look up something my quote on GitHub because I implemented this
for a search engine.
Let me cheat.
How did I do it?
It's gonna go to get up very quickly.
See W3.
I know we have to represent this as wood vectors, but
how do we do it when the woods are of different length? I don't remember.
So I'm going to go to.
I'll show you now. I think I found it.
Oh, this is not well. Yeah, but okay. This one
would be too complicated because then I've talked about something called
a posting.
Anyway, what I'll do is this okay. I will turn this
into a dictionary.
and
how many letters is this how many characters zero?
One two, three, four, five six seven eight nine 10 11. I
will represent these as vectors.
But I need to make them.
basically what I'm trying to show you this when
you do something like this, how is Google able to figure out
And suggest did you meet Apple Mac? How does it do
this?
So let me I need to make this implementation work
and I only have four minutes.
Should this be a probability distribution?
So this is going to be the index. That's
what we call it.
and the word or the query that the user types
is going to be apple.
These will all be
numerical values
How do we do this?
How can I simplify the code?
I have the full implementation, by the way.
It's going to use this from module 4, but I want to do it
now.
Okay, what we do is we will calculate the cosine similarity
of all four all four words.
So let me let me keep this very simple. I will make this.
0.7.
0.3 0.2.
I will make the 0.5 0.5.
zero point
well
That's all we get.
This will be 0.2. I'm just
making up numbers and making sure they're different
0.3 0.5.
0.8.
zero point
2 0.1
now the trick here is also the query has to be made a
distribution
how would I make this distribution?
When it's not even an index.
But we need something called an alphabet and alphabet basically represents every
letter with a number.
You know like UTF encoding.
Well we need to do is we would need to go from we would need
to take every character.
Look up it's encoding like yes, depending on what version
of python you're running and actually
in this case what what point release you're
using?
dictionaries
are
automatically ordered dictionary so you can access them
by an index.
but you have to be careful about what version you
are using because they turned it on and like
3.6 something and they turn it off
and 3.62 and then turned it back on and 3.63.
So, I don't know not sure if you could try it, but basically they
decided at some point that all dictionary should be Auto ordered.
instead of randomly ordered
The order won't matter, but then they turned it on
and off. But if it's auto-ordered then you can access it
by index. Let me tell you why the order is not important.
Let's say the user has typed this one. Correct? We
don't need to go through all of the
then we don't we don't need to go through the entire.
index
because we can say all right, just
look at the first two letters.
It's AP. Well we can do is we can just
extract from the syntax
all the words that begin with ap
and then if we're going to do a cosine similarity, we'll
do cosine similarity only on the words that begin with
again p
so
our search time complexity won't be
all of them. It will be something substantially well.
Less than that.
He yeah, but can you search a dictionary
on a partial keyword?
Yeah, so we can do yes,
we can turn this into well, there
are different implementations of this.
Let me show you something.
So if you want to get the keys of this dictionary would
go.
index dot keys
and that will give us these letters. Now you're saying that in different
implementation of python these may or
may not be ordered, correct?
Right there and by order, I mean they're in the
order. They were entered not not necessary if I
would put catapult up here. Yeah.
If it's using order dictionaries, you could just search
it by you starting its index zero and and walk
through it. But this works too. I mean,
but you still have you still have a list that you have to walk through, right? Mmm.
No.
We would have to sort this array.
Now here's a thing. Yeah. He's the thing
about search engines, right?
they put the entirety of the index which
can be really huge into memory into
random access memory now the computers that
Google have
have
especially large amounts of
Random Access Memory
Because well they want the search to be
instantaneous.
So where time complexity
is a problem?
So for example sorting a large.
list of words space complexity can
Come into handy why well, we don't need we don't
need to yes. This is a list but we can what we
can do is we can turn this list into a binary tree.
We can Traverse it beforehand. This is it.
This is a key Point by the way, we won't do this run in
runtime when the switch is usually we will do this well ahead.
So we can we will spare like one hour or
a couple of hours of the day.
So basically we have this right we have
imagine we have two inverted indices one that has already been sorted and
one that is consistently growing.
So while we are
converting this alphabet this Innovative indexer to
a binary tree and making sure everything is alphabetically sorted
and and the correct order we want
we already have a pre-existing inverted index that's
once we have indexed and converted this
list into a binary research
tree. We will replace the new inverter index with
the old one.
once we have binary search tree implementation
of this in-memory then again we
could
Our search time complexity will become all log oven.
So it will be a fraction of the time.
The point I'm trying to say is the point. I'm trying to make it in practice.
This wouldn't be a problem. So whether it's Alpha
alphabetically sorted or not. We're not going to go through a
list.
We're going to go through a binary binary tree.
He's what I'm going to do since we've run out of time. I'm going to take this.
This is the code I had by the way, this is the source code. I'm referring
to so, this is for an actual project we had.
Where we use cosine similarity to go now. This is
a small subset of the inverted index.
the
actual search engine has millions of
web pages. So it's a very large.
the dictionary of words
So what I'll do is I will.
Use this code I will modify this code and obviously add
comments to it so you can see how cosine similarity
could be used to do.
this
I mean, we just looked at an example where we compared the words
wooden dog to building.
and we've seen
You know how cosine similarity can help us and how
we can go from political Cartesian space, but I
I want to include this because later on
we're going to reference it in module 4.
Anyway, that's it for today's session Everyone. By the
way, if you did not notice I posted.
the first assignment
very similar to
the linear program store we did in module 1
so just keep
just keep that in mind. It's due.
next Monday
and very shortly. I'll also post the assignment for module 2.
But thank you for joining me today. I will see you again
on.
Friday
until then. Take care. Bye.